Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for tuning in.
This episode is a followup
and an experimental episode.
Each of these interviews
they're typically interviews,
consists of me trying to
deconstruct a world class performer,
whether they be an investor,
a chess prodigy and athlete or otherwise.
To pull out the tips and
tricks that you can use.
A recent episode that with
Pavel Tsatsouline who is
an elite physical training
instructor. He's been involved
with training the spit nos,
the elite Soviet special forces units,
also the Marine Corps Secret
Service Navy seals. Uh,
he did an episode that ended up being a
masterclass in strength training and it
was so popular that we decided
to do a round two on this.
Round two in both of these can
be listened to independently,
consists of the most popular 15
questions as voted up by hundreds of you.
So hundreds of you submitted
questions voted on them.
The top 15 which covered just about
everything you can imagine are those that
Pavel we'll be answering in this episode.
One piece of housekeeping,
if you are looking for business mentorship
in 2015 and you would like an all
expense paid trip to Necker island,
that's Sir Richard Branson's private
island on a private jet to be mentored by
yours. Truly Sir Richard Branson
and a handful of other folks.
You can get all of the details and
they are very cool details@shopify.com
forward slash Tim,
that's shopify.com forward slash Tim
and if you miss the first interview with
Pavle,
you can search his name,
p a v e l and my name and it will be one
of the first few results on Google or
go to four hour workweek.com
forward slash Pavle Pav,
l all spelled out and you can find
everything including all the links and
resources mentioned in that episode.
Without further ado,
here is round to the Q and a by
popular demand with Pavel Tsatsouline.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
it is my pleasure to be speaking
to Tim Ferriss audience again.
You have asked me a number of
questions, excellent questions. And uh,
I will answer us on them today.
Many of the questions had to do with
nutrition. It is not my specialty,
so I will not be answering
them with one exception.
The question by Carl from
Indiana on the podcast,
you asked Pavle if he had tricks
regarding the challenges of eating for
hypertrophy and he said
he would mention them,
but you guys never had time
to circle back. Well, Carl,
to put on muscle,
it's a very costly proposition for
your body to put it on in, to keep it,
it takes a lot of energy.
It takes a lot of plastic resources
and the buddies very reluctant to add
muscle,
especially past a certain point.
So you must convince it that
food is not only available,
the food is abundant,
the food is overly abundant.
So the tactic used by number of lifters,
top lifters like Kirk Kolasky to get
themselves past a sticking point and keep
putting muscle on was to add a
feeding in the middle of the night.
That's right. You just get some
food, a solid food or liquid food,
high protein food on your nightstand,
something that you wouldn't mind, uh,
gagging down and in the middle of the
night you just throw it down the hatch.
Nobody's said it would be easy and uh,
nobody said it would be health.
Mikey from Dublin is wondering what
is the optimal way to combine strength
training and high it for
training. Obviously there
are many ways of doing that,
but if we were to look for
the minimalist approach,
simply focusing most of your
energy on doing sets of five,
when you do a set of five as confirmed,
both by research and experience in the
trenches gives you the best of both
worlds, delivers muscle and
delivers strength bar to you,
Mikey and muscle too.
The next question is from,
and pardon me if I'm not
pronouncing the name correctly,
Josue led desmo from New York City.
What would be the 80 20 training method
to build strength and overall fitness?
The answer is without any doubt
correct kettlebell training.
When one tries to develop all
fitness components, strength,
endurance, flexibility,
power,
using the same modality,
usually he ends up with a whole lot of
compromises by the kettle bell when used
correctly for some reason allows you to
avoid this problem and develop all these
components to a high level.
We even have an expression
in the Kettlebell world
that what the hell effect.
Let's say that you're doing kettlebell
exercises and suddenly you'd go out and
test yourself at something,
have not been practicing and it
turns out you can do more pull ups.
You can walk with,
they have your weight much faster.
You can lift heavier weight off the
ground. That's the what the hell effect.
And uh,
there are a number of Soviet studies in
the eighties confirming that and in the
last several years there've been a number
of studies done in the West as well
and you can find them on pub med.
Now speaking of specific training program,
I recommend three highest yield exercises
that also have the steepest learning
curve.
They are the one arm swing,
the getup and the goblet squat.
Just do this reaction sizes
that were referred to as a
program minimum every day.
And uh,
I guarantee that you're going to get
a great return on your investment.
Okay.
The next question is from
Jdk from San Francisco.
You mentioned the podcast that prior
to strength training you need proper
alignment.
I struggled with this one side is shorter
than the other and a weaker than the
other. What can I doctor, should I
see and what steps should I take?
First of all,
find a sports sports doctor
or chiropractor who is an
athlete and the lifter and
works with athletes and lifters.
It's a very important step.
My personal rule is I would never go to
a chiropractor who dead lifts less than
I do.
And after that,
I suggest that you find yourself
an fms certified specialist,
fms or functional movement screen. You
can read about it in the four hour body.
Greg Cook is the Osr and uh,
it's a terrific system for assessing your
symmetry and helping you improve your
performance.
Okay.
Jeffrey.
John from Edmonton,
Alberta is writing any tips for
developing conditioning are appreciate it.
Let's start with the efficiency.
That means posture and relaxation.
If your head is sticking forward,
your running speed and endurance
is going to be compromised.
The same thing can be said
about your gas in the ring.
So work on your posture.
Relaxation in the Soviet Union,
it was a standard practice for all kids
in grade school to practice relaxation
exercises.
And it's the same practice that stayed
with all the athletes all the way to the
Olympics.
So these exercises are very simple.
They pretty much mean
shaking your muscles out.
So start shaking you arms,
shaking your legs, vibrate him,
and imagine that you're trying to shake
water off your limbs and practicing
these exercises regularly
between sets of your, uh,
strength exercises during your athletic
practice is going to go a very long way
towards making you more enduring
and making it faster as well.
Yeah.
Uh,
Arctic,
you're a type of running is going to
help you with being more relaxed and more
enduring.
Just go out on a run without looking the
clock and focus and being as relaxed as
possible and go as far as possible
while being as relaxed as possible.
And uh,
as you keep doing that,
eventually all you'll have to do is just
add some gas and you're going to run
faster.
Next item would be strengthening your
respiratory muscles or breathing muscles.
Research tells us that the metabolites
from your respiratory muscles,
which means all the waste
products from this muscles,
makes the blood vessels in
your limbs get constricted.
So think about it this way.
You start sucking wind and then as
if it wasn't bad enough already,
you get this extra punishment of the
plumbing in your legs start shutting down.
So the same research tells us that
strengthening your respiratory muscles is
going to increase your
endurance by preventing this
reflexive Vasa constriction.
How do we do that?
In Our kettlebell practice,
we do something called the
biomechanical breathing match.
So let's say we were performing
as set of swings on the way down.
We sharply inhale into the
abdomen through the nose.
So you're inhaling against the resistance
of your muscles and against the
resistance of the weight and on the
way up you're forcefully exhaling as if
you're striking. That's called
the biomechanical breathing match.
So that's how we strengthen
our breathing muscles.
Then there is such a thing as
the breathing discipline. Uh,
breathing ladder is a very
effective technique developed
bottom of my colleagues
rob Lawrence. Let's say this,
you're doing a set of swings,
kettlebell swings,
or a sprint.
Any type of an exercise
that makes you gassed,
decide that you're going to rest from
this set to the next according to a
certain number of breaths.
So let's say you get to do five
breaths until the next set,
and this is going to discipline
you to slow your breathing down,
slow your physiology down,
stop panicking.
That's also going to
help with your endurance.
One more thing to say is,
uh,
you can develop mitochondria
and your fast twitch fibers,
which is going to enable them
to be much more enduring,
to be able to use oxygen in the podcast.
I already mentioned building up slow
fibers that already come equipped with
Mitochondria,
but you can also build these mitochondria
oxygen using mitochondria into the
existing fast fibers.
So how do we do that?
We do that by exerting the muscle's very
powerfully for a very short period of
time, typically 10, 15 seconds,
and after that resting actively
for a fairly long time.
So a rest work to rest ratio may be as uh,
as high as one to five or even one to six.
That might mean that you would do a ten
second effort followed by 50 seconds of
rest. It seems quite easy, but, uh,
until you realize that you have to
maintain that power output every time,
very high maximum power output.
And you have to do this up
to eventually up to 40 sets.
That's another,
the protocols by professor silly Yana
so arrest actively between this sets,
which means kind of move
around, jog lightly, uh,
shake your muscles out the way.
I told you to do this earlier,
and you can do this couple of times a
week or eventually you can even do this
possibly every day.
Tyler EHC from New Jersey is asking you,
talk a bit in the interview with Tim
about how important it is in exercise
sports in life to be able to
switch yourself on and off.
What are your favorite
techniques for making this rapid,
efficient and achievable by anyone?
It's true that most people exist between
the on and the off switch and they're
unable to really turn on
to put out high power.
They are unknown enabled to really switch
off and enjoy some rest or just have
some endurance.
So there's several things that you can do.
One hour to mentioned is those uh,
relaxation exercises,
fast and loose exercises,
just shake your limbs.
And other technique
that you could use is a,
it's an old technique called Jacobson's
per progressive relaxation training.
It pretty much means lying down and then
progressively tensing all your muscles
and then relaxing them in a,
in a particular order that makes you
aware of the tension and then makes you
release the tension through all the day.
And during your training,
you should be particularly aware of your
facial tension because that takes a lot
of effort and it does drain you.
So be impassive
meditation, breathing exercises
from Yoga, from Cathay and so on.
Definitely very helpful.
One of the comes to turning yourself on.
The first thing you can do is do
a proper set of morning exercises.
So I've had to research decades ago
established that if you do at pleasant,
not exhausting a series of
exercises in the morning,
just some sort calisthenics,
joint rotations, arm swings,
whatever you will accelerate,
you will accelerate your ability to
perform at a high level by a couple hours.
So you will reach that peak of performance
early in the morning as opposed to
waiting for it later and later
throughout the day. Your ability to,
uh, access that performance is
going to be greater as well.
Back to breathing practices. There
are some special exercises in, uh,
some oriental practices like Cathay.
There's the bookie breathing that
helps you to turn yourself on,
get some more power,
get some more aggression.
I strongly recommend one book to the
book is called Psych by Dr Bai's Soto.
Doctor Dad buys Soto by his own admission,
looked like a 11 year old stamp collector,
and yet he proceeded to began one of
the most successful power lifters in
history at the age of
44 after back surgery,
he's squatted over 600 pounds at body
weight of one 32 which is absolutely
amazing and he achieved that ability
largely through his mental training,
jogged reached the point where he would
wait for his attempt as other lifters
are waiting for their attempts.
Judd would be just sleeping and then just
a couple of minutes before the attempt,
his coach would wake him up,
he would get up,
he would work himself into a frenzy.
He would go out,
lift a record,
and then just go back to sleep.
Now that's an amazing control of
your on switch and you're off switch.
The title of the book again is
psych by Dr Judd Baez. Soto,
spelled B.
I A. S. O. T. T. O. Josh
Elbaz from Montreal is asking,
what's the quickest way to improve a
strict barbell military press from three
quarters of your body
weight to body weight?
Given that my grip and
abs are already strong,
Russian weightlifters have a saying
to press a lot. You must press a lot.
The press responds exception, the wealth
through a high volume of training.
What does it mean typically 20 to 50
reps per session three times a week.
That's a lot of presses. All these
presses are done in low repetitions,
one to five more typical to three and
four, but one to five. That's the range.
And you never go to a failure.
So typically you stay with one third
to two thirds of your Max Reps.
So what does it mean?
It means that if you're able
to do 10 reps with that weight,
you should really only be
doing three to six repetitions.
So one more time to press a lot.
You must press a lot.
Could you elaborate a neurological
strengths? Please? Asks. Reimagined. Yes.
From Miami,
Florida.
Think of your muscles as
a six cylinder engine.
And right now you are firing
only on three cylinders.
You could get stronger by adding
several more cylinders and that'll be
hypertrophy or you could fix that engine
and learn how to take advantage of the
cylinders you already do have.
That's the essence of
neurological strength training.
Pretty much what you do is you learn how
to activate your muscles more intensely.
It's done by training with low repetitions
is done by training with heavier
weights.
It's done by a perfect practice.
Approaching your training, not
as a workout, but as a practice.
Nick m from Erie,
Pennsylvania is asking in the podcast,
it's mentioned that to build
strengths you shouldn't go to failure.
How do you know when to add more
weight if you're not going to failure?
And Kaelin from Denver
as a similar question,
you need to use your
perceived rate of exertion.
So on the scale of one to 10 let's say
that your typical sets takes you eight
units of effort and you were staying
with this weight and couple of weeks from
now lifting the same weight takes
six or seven units of effort.
You know that you've gotten stronger.
Kid from San Francisco is asking what
is the best way to gain strength as you
get older,
his book power to the people espoused
heavy lifts but going on 39 years old,
I'm finding that this routine is way
all cabs way too hard on my joints.
Step one,
go get your joints checked by a doctor.
Step two,
get your head in the right place.
My father is 77 years old and he's done
lifting or for a hundred pounds without
a belt and he does not
think himself as old.
Yeah,
Dylan from Los Angeles is wondering when
does the five minute rest between sets
apply,
when does it not?
There are three types of rest intervals.
There is ordinary stress and stimulating
an ordinary interval allows you to
pretty much recover your performance level
by the time the next set rolls around
and that's roughly three to five
minutes as stress interval I accumulated
fatigue.
So the more sense you,
the more tired you get and finalists
stimulating interval allows you to perform
better in the next set and
then may take 12 minutes or so.
So unless your training
program says otherwise,
just go with the ordinary interval
at about three to five minutes.
Trey from Denver,
Colorado is asking,
the army still has sit ups
in the physical fitness test,
any advice and training in
maximizing the repetitions.
First, get your abs strong, really strong.
That means three to five sets of three
to five reps with three to five minutes
in between of an exercise that puts a
lot of tension on your abdominal muscles.
That could be strict hanging
leg raises. That can be, uh,
the abdominal wheel,
that can be strict weighted sit ups.
So once you've gotten that strength,
then just do a very minimal practice of
your repetitions set up test and you'll
have no problem.
Okay.
Swash from Columbus,
Ohio is asking,
I know the deadlift is
one of the best exercises,
but I've gotten terrible back
spasms from doing it. Is it my form?
Can I have proximity?
They deadlifts effects with something
else that doesn't possibly injure me.
Step one,
see a duck and lifting doc.
Find out what your restrictions
and limitations are.
Either you will learn that you
can deadlift with proper form,
possibly with some corrective exercises
or you have to look for an alternative.
If the answer to the deadlift is yes,
then find a coach,
a good power lifting coach
and learn how to do trite.
If the answer is no as good
doctor for some other suggestions,
ask your doc above the Kettlebell swing.
Very often people who are not able to
lift heavy barbells are able to safely do
the Kettlebell swing.
H F VK from Norway who appears to be a
personal trainer is asking how would you
go about building the discipline
required to be great in a client?
Stop treating people
you're training as clients,
hair salons of clients.
A client is somebody who's
passively receiving a service.
You want them to think of themselves as
students and you want to treat them as
students.
Tim, thank you for having me on your
show, ladies and gentlemen, bar too.
Okay.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show
is brought to you by 90 designs.
99 designs is the world's largest online
marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years,
including to get cover concepts
for the four hour body,
which went on to become number one New
York Times Number One Wall Street Journal.
It was a huge hit and here's how it
works and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions.
You can see these book covers and so
on@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim
with you need a logo, a car wrap,
a web design and APP, a thumbnail,
a tee shirt,
whatever.
You go to 99 designs.com you describe
your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around
the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas
and designs and drafts.
You have an original design that you
love or you pay nothing. It is fantastic.
I have used it.
I have mentioned it before,
including in the four hour work
week as a resource. Check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash
Tim and if you use that link,
you'll be able to see what
I've done on the platform.
You will also get $99
as an upgrade for free,
which will get you more designs,
more submissions. So check it out.
And until next time,
thank you for listening.